.
HERE'S SEAN.
>> Sean: A SHORT TIME AGO, JAPAN
ISSUED A WARNING TO ITS CITIZENS
TO TAKE SHELTER AFTER THEY
DETECTED A MISSILE LAUNCHED FROM
NORTH KOREA BY LITTLE ROCK MAN.
HE'S BACK AT IT.
HE FIRED IT IN THEIR DIRECTION.
THANKFULLY IT LANDED, AND THE
THREAT HAS NOW PASSED.
WE CAN NOW SEE, THE WORLD WORLD,
CAN SEE ALL THE HOSTILE RAMSEY
REGIMESAROUND THE GLOBE, THERE Y
EMBOLDENED BY A WEAK UNITED
STATES PRESIDENT?
36 DAYS UNTIL THE MIDTERMS,
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO DEBATE,
AND THEY'RE NOT GETTING PRESS
QUESTIONS FROM THE NEWS MEDIA.
WE'LL CHECK WITH SENATOR JOHN
KENNEDY.
AND JUST BREAKING MOMENTS AGO,
HERSCHEL WALKER WILL RESPOND TO
AN RECALL, FIRST BY "THE NEW
YORK TIMES," QUESTIONING HIS
RACIAL IDENTITY.
AND ALSO HE WILL RESPOND TO
ANOTHER ARTICLE THAT BROKE FROM
THE DAILY BEAST, CLAIMING HE
PAID FOR A WOMAN TO HAVE AN
ABORTION.
HE'S DENYING IT VEHEMENTLY,
VOWING TO SUE FOR DEFAMATION.
HE WILL TELL HIS SIDE OF THE
STORY STRAIGHT AHEAD.
ALSO TONIGHT, GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS WILL JOIN US IN A
MOMENT WITH AN IMPORTANT UPDATE
FROM HIS STATE.
SOME ARE SAYING SANIBEL ISLAND
MAY BE INHABITABLE, ESTIMATES AS
HIGH AS $100 BILLION IN STORM
DAMAGE ON TOP OF AT LEAST 68
LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN LOST HERE.
DESPITE THE HORRIFIC DAMAGE FROM
THE HURRICANE, HURRICANE IAN, AN
ARMY OF RECOVERY WORKERS ARE ON
THE GROUND, WELL STAGED AS YOU
CAN SEE.
THIS WAS BEFORE, LIKE THREE
FOOTBALL FIELDS, FULL OF ALL
THESE ELECTRIC COST TO GO AND
MAKE REPAIRS AND RESTORE POWER.
THAT WAS THERE BEFORE THE STORM.
THEY HAVE NOW RESTORED OVER 80%
OF THE STATE'S DAMAGED
ELECTRICAL GRID.
AS WE SPEAK AROUND THE CLOCK,
RESCUE RECOVERY EFFORTS ACROSS
THE STATE ARE CONTINUING.
ALL WHILE DEMOCRATS IN
WASHINGTON, THEY TYPICALLY PLAY
POLITICS, AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
ON FRIDAY, VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS ANNOUNCED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE DOLING OUT
HURRICANE RELIEF FUNDS ON THE
BASIS OF RACE.
ALL IN THE NAME OF EQUITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I KNOW WE ARE ALL THINKING
ABOUT THE FAMILIES IN FLORIDA
AND PUERTO RICO, WITH FIONA, AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO HELP THEM
IN TERMS OF AN IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE AND AID.
IT IS OUR LOWEST INCOME
COMMUNITIES, OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR, THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED BY
THESE EXTREME CONDITIONS, AND
IMPACTED BY ISSUES THAT ARE NOT
OF THEIR OWN MAKING.
AND SO WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS
IN A WAY THAT IS ABOUT GIVING
RESOURCE BASED ON EQUITY,
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE FIGHT FOR
EQUALITY, BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
FIGHT FOR EQUITY.
UNDERSTANDING NOT EVERYONE
STARTS OUT AT THE SAME PLACE.
>> Sean: HOW ABOUT WE HELP
EVERYBODY IN NEED, AND NOT
FACTOR IN RACE?
A SHORT TIME LATER, THE FEMA
DIRECTOR REJECTED KAMALA HARRIS'
BIZARRE RACE-BASED HURRICANE
RELIEF PLAN, REASSURING PEOPLE
OF FA, ALL COMMUNITIES WILL BE
SUPPORTED.
OVER THE WEEKEND, THE VICE
PRESIDENT WAS NOT INTERESTED IN
ANSWERING A SINGLE QUESTION
ABOUT HER PRETTY DESPICABLE
BRAND OF RACIAL POLITICS.
WATCH THIS.
>> VICE PRESIDENT, CAN YOU
CLARIFY WHAT YOU MEANT ABOUT
EVENING WITH IT FOR HURRICANE
--EQUITY FOR HURRICANE RELIEF?
>> Sean: SADLY FOR DEMOCRATS,
EVERYTHING IS VIEWED THROUGH THE
PRISM OF THIS, EVEN HURRICANE
RELIEF.
HER VERY CONFUSED LOOKING
HUSBAND CLAIMED HE WAS RAISED IN
DELAWARE BY PUERTO RICANS.
OKAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MY NAME IS JOE BIDEN.
I DON'T WANT THE HEADLINE TO
READ BIDEN BRINGS STORM TO
PUERTO RICO.
I HAVE TO CUT THIS SHORT.
I WAS SORT OF RAISED IN THE
PUERTO RICAN COMMUNITY AT HOME.
NEW YORK SENT NOT ONLY A
CONGRESSWOMAN IN CONGRESS,
$163 MILLION TO BEGIN
CONSTRUCTION ON THE CANAL TO --
HELP ME WITH THE PRONUNCIATION.
MARTIN PENA, THAT ENTIRE
ECOSYSTEM.
I USUALLY DON'T TALK THAT FAST.
>> Sean: AND WHERE IS JACKIE?
JOE BIDEN LOOKS WORSE THAN EVER,
BUT THE MEDIA MOB IS MORE
INTERESTED IN ATTACKING EITHER
DONALD TRUMP OR FLORIDA GOVERNOR
RON DESANTIS FOR NOT
IMAGINICALLY PREDICTING THE
HURRICANE'S EXACT PATH WEEKS
AHEAD OF TIME, AND ON SUNDAY
THIS IS HOW THE GOVERNOR
RESPONDED TO THE GOT YOU
QUESTION FROM FAKE NEWS CNN THAT
SAYS THEY'RE GOING BACK TO THE
MIDDLE.
NOT REALLY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHY DO YOU STAND BEHIND LEE
COUNTY'S DECISION TO NOT HAVE
THE MANDATORY EVACUATION UNTIL
THE DAY BEFORE THE STORM?
>> WHERE WAS YOUR INDUSTRY
STATIONED BEFORE THE STORM HIT?
WHERE YOU IN LEE COUNTY?
NO.
YOU WERE IN TAMPA.
THEY WERE FOLLOWING THE WEATHER
TRACK AND HAD TO MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON THAT.
YOU KNOW, 72 HOURS, THEY WON'T
EVEN IN THE CONE.
48 HOURS THEY WERE ON THE
PERIPHERY.
>> Sean: THE GOVERNOR SENT A
STRONG MESSAGE TO WOULD-BE
LOOTERS, REMINDING THAT THE FREE
STATE OF FLORIDA VALUES OUR
SECOND AMENDMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DON'T EVEN THINK ABOUT
LOOTING, TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
PEOPLE IN THIS VULNERABLE
SITUATION.
YOU CAN HAVE PEOPLE BRINGING
BOATS INTO SOME OF THESE
ISLANDS, TRYING TO RANSACK
PEOPLE'S HOMES.
I CAN TELL YOU, IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA, YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT MAY
BE LURKING BEHIND SOMEBODY'S
HOME.
AND I WOULD NOT WANT TO CHANCE
THAT IF I WERE, GIVEN WE'RE A
SECOND AMENDMENT STATE.
>> Sean: JOY REED WAS OFFENDED
BY THAT STATEMENT.
ON TWITTER, SHE INSINUATED THAT
RON DESANTIS WAS RACIST, AND
COMPARED HIM TO A
SEGREGATIONIST, REMINDING PEOPLE
NOT TO LOOT, AND IT IS A SECOND
AMENDMENT STATE.
HOW DOES THAT FIT?
APPARENTLY ACCORDING TO REED,
IT'S RACIST TO BE AGAINST
LOOTING.
IS THAT THE TAKEAWAY OF THIS?
AGAIN, THE LEFT SEES EVERYTHING
THROUGH THE LENS OF IDENTITY
POLITICS, COMM